[Applause]
he'll teach you
max will give you lessons seven dollars
an hour right that's right i can't
afford it
now uh you know this is this is exciting
because
uh as you know we're here together now
which i know is a big thrill for you
but we work together
why would people laugh at that now it's
an angry crowd
oh big it's a big big thrill um try and
calm yourself
uh we work
we work together what we did well that's
why we're old friends
yes we worked together i think it was 11
years ago we're trying to figure it out
backstage saturday night live
the i believe is the fifth time i was
able to host the show was the fifth time
and there was a sketch called the five
timers club which was the first time the
five-timers club appeared
yeah then they re-ran that idea a bunch
of times but uh
i was uh i was in that in that sketch
it's funny they
they told me that you i said really cody
was in that sketch because the host has
a lot of things he's got to keep track
of
when he's on the show and i i i'm just
staying so i'm interested in seeing this
it's my theory tom that that my
performance here
launched you those oscars came
after this everything came after this
this is truth
uh i think we should take a look at this
great moment fabulous take a look
welcome mr hanks oh once again
congratulations on your
fifth appearance oh well thank you thank
you would you like your uh club robe now
oh sure
yeah yeah you bet thank you um uh sean
sean wait there you go tom
right there now can i say
this is miraculous i have not aged a day
you have not aged today and yet you
i hit puberty yeah i was like 28 years
older higher mr house
i don't think it was 11 years ago i i
think that was from 1958
i think that was from right i think that
although it looks like i'm not doing a
lot there i think
i'm doing quite a bit that was it that
was it actually that was a good piece
steve martin showed up in that piece
john lovitz those were the days and
believe it or not you know
in that piece ralph nader is in that
piece that's right ralph nader plays a
pivotal role comes at the door and says
look i i've hosted the show once
right ralph nader ran for president
i like how this became a civics lesson
and i believe he almost won in a couple
of states
they're still counting the thing i don't
know they're still like why why go back
to that you're going to
go back to that you're right i'm sorry
that's not right at all
are you enjoying i mean here it is
friday we're we're almost at
christmas we're close you can taste it
you can taste
christmas which sounds disgusting but
you can
we're getting that close are you feeling
the christmas spirit you know i i wish i
did
it's uh look i don't want to complain to
the lucky man but to have a movie
come out at the holiday season means
you're pretty much riding that celebrity
mule train for the month of december
and i have not been able to i mean i
have not been able to shop i've not been
able to celebrate i haven't gone to any
of the parties that have been in the
neighborhood
the whole christmas thing seems to be
bypassing me this year
it's really sad i have something but i
don't know it's like i have an idea
what if what if i brought christmas to
you right now wouldn't that be nice
but conan how
how could you bring christmas to me are
you some benevolent spirit of television
it's so simple tom i can do it easily
[Applause]
i'm a god uh let's start out let's have
a little can we
max a little christmasy music maybe set
the mood here for
for tom isn't that nice
you feeling a little christmas right now
sure yeah you bet
you don't seem convinced what if we
brought in a little bit of snow
liz a little bit of snow
well that that sure says christmas yeah
isn't that great and look tom look what
i got you
i got you a big present look at that
this is for me this is for you that's
nice this is from me to you
check this out oh it's it's beautiful
conan it's a skeleton
it's hooch everybody that's hooch
that's i thought great like to have
hooch back in your life
it's great to have a skeleton of one of
my old co-stars
that's great and then i thought maybe
maybe what i should do to really set the
mood is
sing a little christmas song how about
it
have yourself a merry
little christmas let your
heart be live
from now on tom hanks troubles
will be out of sight
conan have yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
from now on our troubles will be
[Music]
[Applause]
a merry little christmas
[Applause]
tom hanks everybody there's no one
better
hillary